let's talk about old people in sex that
makes everybody happy we're dedicating
this segment to Blanche Devereaux by the
way old people are getting more stds
than ever we've got proof between two
thousand eleven and two thousand twelve
STI sexually transmitted infections
increased by three percent for those
between 45 and 65 and seven percent for
those over 60 when it comes to
forgetting about safe sex we always
think of the vulnerability of young
people but there's the Fifty Shades of
Grey effect where older people are being
more explorative but not necessarily
remembering to use a condom that's from
dr. Jones is the chairwoman of the
British Medical Association's GP
committee so ya go but first of all uh
David pointed out that sti's is more
politically correct than STDs who was
making that argument yeah what I did you
gonorrhea has always been super uppity
about that yeah you know but we do have
weird things about STDs and what we call
them right cuz was in what which one was
the clap that was a gonorrhea would you
rather have a disease or infection right
that's all day they don't know well I
don't know i read an infection in a
disease i think i'd rather i think i'd
rather have a disease and infection can
give you sepsis I'm I'm afraid of sepsis
you fear SEPs I fear sepsis Errol
Thomson I acceptances wanted is
infection goes horribly horrible you
know what sets yet you know that you
need to watch more house uh results eps
it's all sepsis yet uh yes all people
having more sex and then look they were
in uh they don't easy on the old people
older all right sir youyou 45 to 65 they
still have sex yeah are you guys in the
the 45 to you know but when i get a low
end i predict but yet well now they have
viagra too so i think that probably has
a lot to do with it right so between
viagra and then what they're calling the
Fifty Shades of Grey effect that older
people are being more sexually
expressive yeah but assuming that these
aren't life-threatening conditions so
let's leave out obviously the but I mean
yeah a three percent increase in some
and a seven percent increase in others
might not
worth it I mean it might be worth it did
I use a condom yeah like that like
buying we always I did expect that we
can all accept that and and if they're
expect I figured that this was really a
polite way of saying look how many
people in their fifties are now having
anal sex like but they didn't want to
specific Bell to like oh you know that a
follow-up study that they didn't publish
online why do we get so weird about
older people and sex okay what older
people older 45 all right but when we
think of people having sex naked people
in their twenties pretty much orders I
gotta be enough I know there was a point
I'm curious this in your in your porn
viewing habits uh you're a younger man
Jimmy and I are basically the same
generation there was a moment it
happened on television and it happened
in sort of all fantasy were all of a
sudden like the women I was interested
in were all 38 years old yeah just like
that all of a sudden it went from Nicaea
gorgeous 22 year old and I think she
should be dressing that was right and
and now i watch some show and there's a
beautiful blonde 41 year old on
television on the call that's nice
that's really good on the same way they
say that a lot whoo men are attracted to
has a lot to do with how older mother
was when they were young so I was born
late my mother's life so I'm more
attracted to women who may be over 40
years old let me to my mom was 42 and
that is literally the most depressing
thing I've heard yet months you to make
no no makes it great for me because I'm
married now and I've been with my wife
for 14 years and I'm more attracted to
her another when we first started dating
so working out for me no eyes were yet
it's depressing that you walk is what
that gets do is you wanna [ __ ] your mom
uh at the end of the day this is about
[ __ ] your mouth it always is yeah
well I mean come on they say when you're
in bed there's not just you and your
partner's to you and your partner to
other people up for other people her
parents and your parents are all in bed
together and that they're all kind of
commingling right come on Molly one who
watches what do you are a strict
Freudian is it too late to teach older
people as or what are we gonna call them
out we don't people people people these
people of a higher age is it too late to
teach them all the safe sex tricks
because they didn't grow up with that
with the sec said with exact said and
the
in the having sex as the older person
it's like writing will they stop to yell
get off my mom you know I mean it's up
its gonna grab my lawn but I just wanna
tell that joke no that's good thanks for
explaining yet I could not be home
didn't get it but they don't know what
love is love again Latino i was using it
in turn lieu of the lawn okay i hope
people still do yelled at yet you want
to piss off an old person walk on their
lawn or part of our house yeah it
probably is a little tougher to sort of
drive those points on but again if we're
not seeing about minimizing i guess i am
but a couple they look like chlamydia
you know like big big what penicillin
stuff you're completely fine it could be
cured with an antibiotic what are we
talking about yeah fair enough are you
guys gonna be having sex in your
seventies and eighties I hope so I
certainly hope so with each other with
the other yeah that's where it's gonna
go that's where this is all leading the
sexual tension between you two today I
don't think you do experiment the older
I get I die my desire for sex it's just
my ability right I'm tired I get you
know all that stuff got a boner pill
what have you and so I think I'll always
want to have sex it's just like I but
you just other things get the less like
that my back and hip maybe if I stretch
they'd have a cough you have a headache
right or I could just stay here and be
totally sedentary like that's all we
have that's a very attractive option